conference like at other Summits and
high level meetings on catastrophic
climate change there is no lack of Wars
there is no lack of good definitions and
no shortage of prescriptions for what
the world should do I listened to some
of the speeches today and I agree with
many of the assessments the world is on
the brink and Beyond this limit
devastating changes that will forever
change the usual life on all continents
colleagues have described well what this
means no one can stay aside and the
poorer the person
the poorer the family the poorer the
country the more painful the effects of
climate change will be for them
however this also applies to all rich
Nations it is impossible to buy off the
destruction of the climate but why do we
keep talking about it every year
why instead of reports on what has been
done the same forecasts and appeals are
made every year
I will be honest there are still many
who do not take the climate agenda
seriously and not only in politics but
also in big business
there are still many for whom climate
change is just rhetoric or marketing or
political ritual whatever but not real
action
they are the ones who hamper the
implementation of climate goals they are
the ones in their offices who make fun
of those who fight to save life on the
planet although in public they seem to
support the war for the sake of nature
in every possible way
they are the ones who start wars of
aggression when the plant cannot afford
a single gunshot because it needs Global
joint actions
you all know about the war that Russia
started in Europe trying to destroy the
independence of my country but what does
this war mean
this Russian war has brought about an
energy crisis that has forced dozens of
countries to resume qualified power
generation in order to lower energy
prices for their people at least a
little to lower prices that are
shockingly rising due to deliberate
Russian actions the Russian war brought
an acute food crisis to the world which
hit worse those countries suffering from
the existing manifestations of climate
change catastrophic droughts large-scale
floods the Russian war destroyed five
million Acres of forests in Ukraine in
less than six months not every country
in the world has such an area of forests
that we have burned in Ukraine by
Russian shelling
we have to check every day this
situation at the Parisian nuclear power
plant the largest in Europe
if there is no radiation leaks
the Russian army has turned this nuclear
power plant the factor in their military
training ground
they are constantly playing with
connecting and disconnecting their plant
and nuclear reactors from their power
grid there is a directories of a
radiation disaster who will care for
example about the amount of the
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere is
part of Europe or the middle is and
possibly Northern Africa God's forbid
are covered by a radiation Cloud after
an accident in the Parisian
last year we couldn't even imagine that
kind of question but this year Russia
has paused dozens of such questions to
the world
ladies and gentlemen
world needs honesty we must tell those
who do not take the climate agenda
seriously that they are making a
catastrophic mistake
we must stop those who with their insane
and illegal War are destroying the
world's ability to work United for a
common goal
there can be no effective climate policy
without the peace on the earth because
in fact nations are thinking only about
how to protect themselves Here and Now
from the threats created in particular
by their Russian aggression
Russia needs to shut the guns and hide
its missiles so the wall finally hears
what we can all really do together to
save ourselves from the climate disaster
all of us in Europe Africa Asia America
Australia I invite you
you all to support our initiative
presented here at the conference
creation of a global platform to assess
the impact of military actions on
climate and environment we are all
thinking about how to generate hundreds
of billions of dollars to help
developing countries protect themselves
from the climate change
under these conditions how can anyone
cause additional insane damage to the
nature with their invasive military
ambitions
such Ambitions deserve only punishment
Mr President to visit said an important
thing in his speech we must meet
expectations of the people all over the
world people who are suffering more than
ever I absolutely support this goal we
must ensure that suffering doesn't
multiply because the wall doesn't have
time to respond to climate challenges
but to do this we need joint effective
actions and for them to be we need peace
and I thank everyone who works for peace
I thank everyone who takes seriously the
need to protect life on the earth for
the benefit of all people all nations
all classes all cultures
I thank you for your attention slavo
green